Dobby's real Quirk has just been
revealed in the mha manga we've known
all along that he had a powerful blue
flame Quirk that is even stronger than
Endeavor squirk but now we know that he
also had a secret ice Quirk inside of
him the entire time the clues were there
his hair turning white the fact that he
didn't die after being terribly burned
multiple times and of course his ability
to mimic shoto's phosphor was a major
clue in chapter 387 Dobby's true Quirk
finally awakens and we see that he is
able to not only use his father's flame
Quirk but also his mother's ice Quirk
and since Dobby's Flames are even
stronger than his father's his ice could
be even stronger than his mother's
Dobby's real Quirk has both Fire and Ice
elements just like shotos and these two
elements are about to create something
truly unique and overpowered for more
mha videos subscribe to anime uproar
right now